so let's see hi my name is Johnny hey
guys I'm mark hey guys I'm Utah my name
is Thiago hi I'm Tay let's do it
hey guys I'm too young hi I'm Jo hi I'm
itchin look we are here at BuzzFeed and
we are here to play
[Music]
[Applause]
hey butterfly butterfly you get good
boys that's what you were tell ya I
can't do everything good you want me
[Laughter]
what do you think
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know so we're about into a faceoff
for whoever reaches the higher note and
that goes for Johnny and Jo and we're
about to begin
[Music]
[Music]
I just have the loudest there all right
too much in the need more like what was
crazy was he was having lunch but he was
already thinking of what he was well
what do we wanted to eat for dinner
that's how much you liked things about
[Music]
this goes another phase I think Joe
should go first
and your conversations talking about the
fear yourselves alright so I'm just
gonna see sorry the best term is a very
good cook when he's cooking for a lot of
people the meal after the meal he's
really good at cooking bad for instance
like after robbing you might have like
Robin bokumbap yes Robin PB Bob yeah
Robin Phoebe from up with eggs around
Drummond bokumbap they
Mama's in there here she's gonna dance
around digger ready cucumber kimchi
bokumbap with eggs around yeah yeah it's
me because my hair very perfect he's in
all Jenny's speaks Spanish French
Chinese I've only been pretending this
trick French Chinese Korean Japanese
French Spanish language I can say hi in
those languages one is English number
two is Korean three is Chinese for is
Japanese best worse really bad a
Japanese BAM oh yeah that's about all I
know
[Music]